first being it's an introduction to
sequences what these objects are because
they don't have a unique like connection
to any of the other talking so you've
done so far so I'm gonna introduce some
language for you right now before I even
get to any of these I want to tell you
that object I think called a set some of
you heard of this before
okay a set is a very very basic type of
thing
type of object in mathematics okay some
might say it's the most basic actually a
set is very simply a collection and the
main kind of mathematical objects that
we're interested in are numbers but sets
can contain other things as well okay
now the important thing is it's a bunch
of things right and you just have them
all together and you kind of have our
min apart right here's my set of
whiteboard markers okay and this set of
whiteboard markers I can shuffle them
around I can I can have doubles and I
still have the same set okay so the
important thing is that just this this
collection okay now our secrets takes
that idea and it just adds a little bit
of nuance to it a sequence is a
collection of objects with order right
and you can hear it in the word secrets
like when we say something is sequential
what we mean is these objects are
ordered and that water really everything
really matters okay now I'm gonna talk
about later on we'll see how we go for
time exactly how much it matters you'll
be surprised how much it matters but now
we have two kinds of things here let's
try and compare them okay so not that
it's as important but I will show you
the notation for how to indicate a set
it's very simple you draw one of these
curly braces okay and then you simply
write down whatever number of objects
that you have and on you separate them
by commas okay so for example here is a
set of objects okay and it's important
because it's just it's just a bunch of
things right the order doesn't matter so
these two sets are literally identical
to each other
okay I've changed their order but the
set doesn't care okay just like my
pencil case doesn't care that all the
WIPO Michaels just fly around everywhere
it's the same set of wypall mines
okay it's worth mentioning that this
collection right these two here
they each have three objects in them
there are finite size but they don't
have to be okay in fact most of the sets
that we know about or that you work with
are not fine so we will say they're
either finite you can count the number
of objects in there or they just kind of
go on forever they can be infinite
excuse me now sequences are denoted in
exactly the same way as sets just
without the braces okay so for example
here's a sequence okay now this sequence
one and then four and then seven is
completely different from seven and then
four and they're one different sequences
different rooms okay even though they
have same objects of it now even though
we're not going to really address it
today since we're doing the introduction
I will tell you all what series it is
these ideas nest within each other a set
to collection objects a sequence is what
happens when you take those objects and
you put an order on them and a series is
what happens when you take a sequence
which is ordered and you add them all up
right so this is the sum of a sequence
so instead of 1 comma 4 comma 7 1 plus 4
plus 7 that's a series okay
yeah good sets have like rules that come
in like which position numbers oh no no
not really
and that's what the interesting things
about them my berries a hole is all feed
of mathematics about sets and none of
the things in them care about position
as soon as you as soon as you say
anything about all I want it to be this
and then this and then this
then then you've crossed over into
sequence territory okay and if a
sequence is what we're gonna focus on